[Musique]
elle a le rythme dans la peau laisse
irak automne jeunes breakdance de 25 ans
est venue de chilly-mazarin dans
l'essonne pour participer à la première
compétition de ce type organisée à magny
les hameaux yvelines au maximum la dette
et on a travaillé des trucs et pouvoir
sortir ce qu'on a travaillé et amusé au
maximum
mais ce qui fait partie des dizaines de
break dancer présence ce dimanche 14
avril à la maison de l'environnement
pour emporter les battles des duels de
deux minutes les sportifs doivent
improviser sur des sons venus du hip hop
se laisser un peu prendre par le som
réussir à mettre ces techniques et être
propre et efficace et ans tué sur la
musique tu prends les gens avec
toilettes publiques et ça se fait
naturellement
les sportifs sont ensuite se juger à la
fin de leur performance par un jury de
trois experts un jury il va juger au
feeling mais surtout sur des critères
assez simple comme l'originalité
la musicalité la complexité des
mouvements et ça se
vote à main levée donc comme ils sont
trois voilà dès que la main se lève d'un
côté ou de l'autre
voilà il n'y a pas forcément de critères
définis pour le moment les battles se
sont déroulées tout au long de
l'après-midi en parallèle l'événement
avait également une vocation solidaire
les organisateurs proposé au public et
aux participants de payer leur place en
donnant des denrées alimentaires pour
des associations
au total 120 kg ont été récoltés
[Musique]